لم يكن هذا العام كبقيه الاعوام عاما من
المعاناه فقد فيه الاوكرانيون حياتهم التي
كانوا يعرفونها وتحولوا فيه الى شعب من
المقاتلين منهم من في الثقور على جبهات
القتال واخرون على جبهات الحياه لضمان عدم
انهيار دولتهم وصمودها في وجه الرؤوس
والبقيه يجاهدون باضعف الايمان الصبر على
اوضاع انسانيه كارثيه
احببت بسبب الحرب ولن نستطيع ان نعيد ما
فقدناهم لكننا تعلمنا ان نعيش بشكل مختلف
تودعك بالعام وقد فقدت الاسر الاخرانيه
مئات الالاف من ابنائها انبا قتلى او جرحى
او اسرى والملايين نازحون في ارجاء الارض
وقدمرت الحرب البنيه التحتيه للدوله
والغيت جميع مظاهر الاحتفالات براس السنه
الميلاديه من زينه او حفلات عامه كما شددت
السلطات على الالتزام بمواعيد حظر
التجوالي الذي يبدا قبل منتصف الليل بساعه
مما يجبر المواطنين على استقبال العام
الجديد في بيوتهم
بالتاكيد نستقبل العام الجديد بامل
الانتصار سيكون عام 2023 عام النصر
الاوكرانيا حتما اشهر ان هذا العام سيكون
عام العمل الكبير لنا وللشعبنا ولبلادنا
ونحن حتما سننتصر وبلادنا ستصبح اكثر حريه
وافضل وسنكون فيها سعاده
ان يكون هذا العام
افضل مازلنا احياء
بانتهاء جحيم الحرب فالدوله عازمه على
انهائها لصالح شعبها في صحه القتال او عن
طريق قمه للسلام وفق شروطها ليتفرغ الجميع
لاعاده بناء ما دمرته الحرب وهو دمار هائل
وعوده ملايين النازحين من النساء والاطفال
ولم يشمل شتات الاسر الاوكرانيه فكيف عادل
لقناه العربيه والحدث هي